[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like nuclear science and all technology
has no conscience of its own whether it
will become a Force for good or ill
depends on man
and only if the United States
occupies a position of preeminances
and we help decide
whether this new ocean
will be a sea of peace
or a new terrifying theater of war
China carried out its first
anti-satellite weapons test on an old
weather satellite about 500 miles up
according to U.S government officials
after three misses China succeeded in
shooting down one of its own aging
weather satellites the test may be part
of China's efforts to establish a
military presence in space does this
mean the Spy satellites the United
States depends on could be shot down
they left behind a trail of garbage
circling in orbit now after they blow up
the satellite
it could leave us vulnerable it could
[ __ ] us is that what they're up to
[Music]
there are nations out there who are
hostile to us and they are in Space the
threat to our space security is real
Security in space is a vital National
interest the loss of access to space
would threaten the very stability of our
nation
it aimed at commercial satellites and
such an attack could bring U.S business
and industry to a halt
today China warned that a shooting war
in space would affect everyone on Earth
space can get more crowded and we're
going to need to have control and
defensive measures
Banning space weapons has failed a space
war is in the cards
space is the backbone of our national
security there is no substitute and
there is no alternative to military
dominance in space
this conviction should drive our course
for the next 50 years
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Century Humanity spun its first
satellite into orbit
staking this new frontier provided a new
arena for war
still
space is unscarred by battle
a sanctuary
but Humanity's compulsion to dominate
May ravage the expanse embracing our
world
and the world itself
whom can we trust to regulate our
heavens
[Music]
people in the Roman Empire lived better
under Caesar Augustus than they had in
any Empire on Earth during any previous
time
roads improved
Pirates no longer threatened ships on
the high seas
life was so good during this time
that the period acquired a name
it was and is still referred to as the
Pax Romana which means the Roman peace
another period of Peace has acquired a
name
it is called the pox Americana
or the American piece
[Music]
it refers to the period in which
American influence throughout the world
has caused a relative peace to come
about
nowadays it seems the pox Americana is
threatened
most of us only feel peace when we're
not at War but peace means the presence
of a risen and Alive Lord in your life
you may walk out every morning into a
war zone
the Lord won't take you out of the
Valley of the shadow of death but he
will lead you right through it
so it says in Isaiah 54 though the
mountains be shaken and the hills
removed yet my unfailing love for you
will not be shaken nor my Covenant of
peace be removed
[Music]
thank you
my name is Claire first class Colton
Tuttle I'm a Cadet the Air Force Academy
I graduate in 44 days and I'm just
hoping to do my part to make sure that
everyone here
can enjoy their freedoms
[Music]
Pax Americana is a political view which
simply says that because America is
currently the sole superpower that it
has not only the ability but the
responsibility
into the far future to maintain World
Peace
[Music]
I think our country has always played a
key role in maintaining world peace and
now that responsibility also extends
into space and so in countries like the
Chinese start attacking space assets uh
it could lead to a serious crisis
hopefully we can talk to them before
they start
making a big mess
the United States and particularly its
intelligence services
worry
about an attack on the United States
that is not nuclear weapons that is not
chemicals that is not biological but is
technological
Global Communications are embedded in
our daily lives
miles above our heads beyond our
awareness
satellites manage our hyper-connected
society
if you look at space lots of times you
think about the Hubble telescope or you
know Mars probes but most people don't
realize that they use space every day
[Music]
when you open your cell phone to make a
call
[Music]
when you take money out of the bank with
your ATM card
satellite bring you your TV shows and
live news from around the world
you use them each time you rely on a
positioning system for air foresee for
land traffic control and even in your
own car
there will be no weather forecasting
disaster monitoring without satellites
our entire life
we're not conscious of that until we
lose it
today at least 1 000 active satellites
circle the Earth
45 Nations on these satellites
and most of the world uses their signals
but the United States dominates as the
owner and user of Space Systems both
civilian and Military
bombs on target real-time battle
management
that's what we're about and that's what
we are able to deliver through space air
land and sea and the the capability of
all of those to come together we started
that in Desert Storm we've done that in
each conflict since and we get better
and better and better
foreign
the use of space has become vital to all
U.S military operations
in the second Gulf War
during the shock and awe Air Attack on
Baghdad the United States used
satellites to guide 71 of all the
missiles it fired
space is the backbone of American
military power
or is it it's Achilles heel
a surprise attack in space this is uh
the Ultimate Nightmare
by knocking out 50 U.S military
satellites the Chinese could literally
[ __ ] the U.S military
they could prevent the military from
being able to communicate with its
forces they could blind the U.S
intelligence Community which uses
Electro optic satellites to determine
military force movements around the
world and they could also [ __ ] the
guidance systems that are used on
Precision guided Munitions that are
satellite guided
in many sense it could be a kind of an
electronic Pearl Harbor
[Music]
without space the U.S would be unable to
conduct any type of military operation
in an effective way
[Music]
there's a tremendous premium on the
United States being able to prevent
other people from attacking our Assets
in space and to ensure that we can
continue to exercise full use of them
and if necessary also to be able to deny
others use of similar assets for their
own purposes
[Music]
the world has changed as more and more
countries develop a presence in outer
space the possibility of a space battle
is no longer science fiction
our new world requires new Solutions
meet U.S Air Force Base command this
Elite Force is America's Eye in the Sky
keeping watch over our interests high
above the ground
[Music]
laughs
denial implies
the use of Force weapons from space to
the ground as China recognizes that the
military dominance the United States is
utterly Reliance upon space
the United States is going to become the
world's policeman does that title
resonate with you do you have any
reactions to that do you think is
accurate if it were accurate how would
it play out
if you look at what was one of the first
roles of the United States Navy when it
was established was combating piracy
absolutely and uh if you look at you
know potential Commerce in space law
enforcement and things like that are
going to be an important Mission there's
more and more countries start using
space for security purposes and Military
purposes uh sooner or later they're
going to collide and sooner or later
this place will become another arena for
Warfare for good or bad and the same
kind of Ethics that we apply to military
force in the other environments will
apply to space you can obviously stretch
any analogy to the breaking point but
the space AC analogy I think is uh is
one of the more useful
[Applause]
as the Dutch controlled the seas in the
1700s as the British tended to police
and control the Seas from the 1800s and
1900s and as the United States has done
in the 20th century and will do in the
21st century and that is to ensure that
Commerce is unfettered Pirates and
others should they be out there are
taken out
we can do the same thing for space we
can do so in a way that is good for
everyone and is good for ourselves it is
policing the heavens for the good of all
may I have the spelling of your vessel's
name captain
if you object when the United States
Navy deploys hundreds of heavily armed
warships in every one of the world's
oceans
no one accuses us of contributing to the
weaponization of the sea because they
know that the presence of our weapons
ensures free transit for all who pursue
their peaceful interests
U.S systems based in space could
similarly Patrol the commons for the
good of all
the U.S Air Force has been charged with
the mission
of ensuring space access and denying
space access in times of conflict
can the United States Air Force do this
Mission without weapons
constitutes a space weapon
how much do we know about the ability of
the United States to police the heavens
and deny access to others
[Music]
Starfire has been used primarily in the
past to do research on satellite
tracking also they've done a lot of work
in astronomy with range finding of stars
who use the laser to be able to help
tell you where the star is and how far
away it is in the budget documents from
the Air Force there has also been
mention of the use of Starfire for
anti-salite weapons at activities
the Air Force told Congress that it had
no intentions of using Starfire for
anything related to anti-salite weapons
however they are doing a test to make
the laser beam very skinny
and make it stay very stable as it goes
up and they're going to Target that on a
salad
[Music]
if you're tracking a satellite you don't
need a very skinny
laser beam in fact you want kind of a
wide one because you want to be make
sure you catch it in the view right
so
many of us here are concerned that this
kind of a test is actually an
anti-satellite weapons test in disguise
[Music]
in April of 2005 the Air Force launched
an experimental satellite its name was
the
xss-11 theoretically
this experimental microsatellite has the
ability to disrupt other nations
satellites
has it done so no
could it do so or press Heap okay but in
reality
we don't know
one of the things that I think people
need to know is that most technology
that's used in space can be used either
for weapons purposes or it can be used
for totally benign good purposes lasers
for tracking good idea more precise
tracking
um small micro satellites that can go
around a big satellite and take pictures
good idea because it helps you figure
out what went wrong with your satellite
and that's hard to do right now good
idea that same little micro satellite
that's going around the big satellite
could be sent up to go around another
person's satellite and run into it and
kill it
foreign
the technology doesn't know whether it's
a weapon or whether it's a you know a
benign use
the question is going to come down to
the intent of the people who are
building these systems
[Music]
how can we discern peaceful or hostile
intentions for any system projected into
space
how can we know that the weaponization
of space hasn't already begun
foreign
[Music]
I'm the permit professor and head of the
Department of astronautics here at the
Air Force Academy and we've been
continually teaching the fundamentals of
astronautics to our Cadets and every
Cadet that has graduated from the Air
Force Academy almost 40 000 now have
taken at least one course in our
department this area right here what's
that called
bow shock right and superimposed on this
of course we have a heo
highly elliptic orbit they started
military strategy it shows that if you
want to control the battlefield you need
to be the first in seizing The High
Ground the most advanced Frontier
whether it be land sea air and now space
the person that controls that has the
advantage so making sure that we can
deny our enemies space is a huge
advantage
[Applause]
[Music]
military forces have always relied upon
High Ground Technologies to gain
advantages
it's in her own Civil War in the United
States
troops in the Army especially in the
Union Army used hot air balloons to get
above the trees and see where the enemy
was and of course the first airplanes to
be used in World War One were
essentially reconnaissance craft they
were designed to fly up and look and see
where the enemy was placed
space then has been called the ultimate
High ground and the advantage to the
state that can seize and maintain The
High Ground is the same as holding The
High Ground throughout history whether
that was a hill a mountain or in in the
latter half of the 20th century the air
space
September 6 1944 armed with over a ton
of high explosives Germany's first
tactical rocket now called the V2 the
Vengeance weapon is fired at London
[Music]
Hitler's Army pioneered the new high
ground with the V2 rocket
Vengeance Weapon 2 was the first
man-made object rejected through space
on route to Targets in Europe
foreign
[Music]
Dora
[Music]
a young SS officer Werner Von Braun was
chief engineer for the design and
manufacture of the V2
this first ballistic missile sparked the
interest of a rich Patron Beyond Germany
[Music]
Occidental
[Music]
they don't care foreign
[Music]
and his team of German rocketeers to
design an improved version of the V2
on bronze spearheaded production of the
Redstone the first American ballistic
missile
it propelled him to the highest fear of
military and scientific influence Banner
Von Brown ultimately became associate
director of NASA and his uh former Nazi
scientist functioned as collaborators
with the U.S military
and uh
looking towards space as a new Arena of
War
a gentlemen will you please take your
seat so we begin today's conference
I take great deal of pleasure in
presenting to you today as our guest
speaker Dr Werner Von Braum kendallen
the conquest of outer space is the
greatest technological challenge of the
age in which we live
on the right side of this picture you
see a large wheel shaped space station
this of course offers tremendous
possibilities to reconnaissance and both
in the civilian sense as in the military
sense
these Nazi scientists these Nazi space
scientists that came to this country
under Project Paperclip developed
schemes
to essentially control the Earth from
space with space-based weapons it seems
even feasible to use such a platform in
space as a beast or the bombing of
objects on the ground and it is my
opinion that such bombing could be
carried out with an unprecedented
accuracy from such a station
foreign
then October 4th 1957. Russia shocks the
Free World the USSR hurls into orbit the
world's first Earth satellite Sportsnet
ONE
the Soviets are now the unquestionable
leaders in the race for space we've been
assigned the mission of launching a
scientific Earth satellite a promise to
secretary of the army that we would be
ready in 90 days or less let's go Werner
Verna Von Braun met the U.S military's
90-day deadline
his modified V2 launched the first
American satellite into orbit
Space Race was on he uses flash to the
long-awaited event America has Earth
satellite you know
[Music]
how would Nations legislate this new
realm
well I joined the American diplomatic
service in 1958 and I was assigned to
the United Nations political office
and I was 22 years old I was the
youngest Foreign Service Officer in the
state department and they said why don't
you handle the multilateral aspects of
our space program we just put our first
satellites into space and they said
you're in charge and I said you've got
to be kidding I'm only 22 and they said
that's that's your job
today
It Is unscarred by conflict
no Nation hold the concession there
it must remain this way nothing was
settled when we started
for instance who owns who owns outer
space who owns the moon who owns Mars
uh was it the situation like Columbus
discovering the new world whom he says I
lay claim to America in the name of
could we do that could the Russians do
that so that was a big question and the
other question is are we going to use
outer space for peaceful purposes or for
military and aggressive purposes we must
develop new Concepts which enable us
let's say something like 10 years from
now to land parties on the moon to
decide whether we want to have a face on
the moon for scientific or military
purposes and we thought to ourselves
can't there be one part one one sector
that is free of weapons but when it got
to the peaceful uses question uh we I I
ran into the Department of Defense
and they said no we don't want to give
up the idea of putting weapons into
outer space
we'll go along with not having weapons
of mass destruction in outer space but
we're not going to sign on a treaty
where we can't put up weapons
I lost the State Department lost the
Department of Defense one and we ended
up with a treaty in the 1967 treaty
which said you can't orbit weapons of
mass destruction but it did not prohibit
other weapons
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS compelled by the influence of the
defense department endorse the
militarization of space
[Music]
nuclear weapons were now banned from
space
but on Earth they were proliferating
[Music]
with both sections of this divided World
in possession of unbelievably
destructive weapons mankind approaches
the state where Mutual Annihilation
becomes a possibility
first satellites in themselves
have no direct present effects upon the
nation's security
however there is real military
significance to these launches
yeah
dreading nuclear attack the US and USSR
longed to know the position and power of
its enemy stockpiles
[Music]
satellites to spy day and night over the
others Arsenal
the military contest to occupy the
ultimate High Ground had begun
the United States plotted the next step
to weaponize face
covertly
in the early 80s
June 12 1982.
there was a huge demonstration in New
York City that day almost a million
people were protesting against nuclear
weapons at that time the height of the
cold war between the United States and
the former Soviet Union but I watched it
on television and after it was over they
cut away to a right-wing conference and
the speaker that day was a man by the
name of Lieutenant General Daniel Graham
and at that time he was Ronald Reagan's
head of SDI Strategic Defense Initiative
someone said General Graham aren't you
worried about that demonstration in New
York today they say there's almost a
million people there protesting against
nuclear weapons he said no I think it's
fantastic
they're out there protesting against
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
we're moving into space they don't have
a clue let them keep doing what they're
doing
what if we could intercept and Destroy
strategic ballistic missiles before they
reached our own soil or that of our
allies
it will take years probably Decades of
effort on many fronts there will be
failures and setbacks just as there will
be successes and breakthroughs
but isn't it worth every investment
necessary to free the world from the
threat of nuclear war
my fellow Americans tonight we're
launching an effort which holds the
promise of changing the course of human
history
I ask for your prayers
and your support
thank you
good night when I joined the staff of
the committee on armed services in the
U.S House of Representatives back in
1985. my first assignment was to
investigate and oversee the Strategic
Defense Initiative this was President
Ronald Reagan's Star Wars program this
new National strategy represents a break
from the dangerous policy of mutual
assured destruction
in Ronald Reagan's version of Star Wars
the new space shuttle would deploy the
force when our reconnaissance systems
verify a Soviet launch U.S interceptors
are fired as level one defense goes into
action batteries of orbiting weapons
would be poised to defeat a nuclear
attack
before it reached U.S airspace
[Music]
at the time the prevailing view was that
this was going to work that the
technology was almost in hand and that
this was going to change everything I
remember the briefing I got from my
staff director who said not just
anti-missile systems but all major
weapon systems were going to move to
space that space was the new High Ground
even then we talked about it in that way
where where all major military
operations were going to be by the the
end of that Century it was a debate of
Stellar proportions the nation's number
one star gazer versus the pentagon's
chief of Star Wars it cannot protect the
population of the United States
it can be by the Soviets overwhelmed
outfoxed underflown I for one am not
willing and able to just accept the idea
that it can't work
most Star Wars plans proved too fanciful
and went no further than animations
devised for publicity
but the US military stayed committed to
Star Wars
[Music]
as the U.S became the sole superpower
Pentagon maintained its plan to use
space weapons against enemy attacks
Star Wars resurfaced in the early 21st
century under a new name missile defense
[Music]
we need a new framework that allows us
to build missile defenses to counter the
different threats of today's world we'll
also move forward on ballistic missile
defense cooperation we must develop and
we must deploy effective missile
defenses
back in 2000 when President Bush took
office
he and his
Cadre people that surrounded him you
think of Paul wolfowitz you think that
Donald Rumsfeld yeah you think of Dick
Cheney all of them really only had two
priorities one was to get rid of Saddam
Hussein the second was to build a
missile defense system
good morning
I've just concluded a meeting of my
National Security Council
we reviewed what I've discussed with my
friend President Vladimir Putin over the
course of many meetings
many months
and that is the need for America
to move beyond the 1972
anti-ballistic missile treaty
when George W bush became president
immediately he gave six-month notice
to Russia that we're pulling out the
United States is pulling out of the ABM
Treaty the anti-ballistic missile treaty
that limited the United States's ability
to test and deploy
anti-satellite weapons so-called missile
defense systems and other space
technology at the Pentagon today a
warning that space will become the next
big Battlegrounds to meet the challenge
defense secretary Donald Rumsfeld is
making space a top Pentagon priority
putting a four-star general at the head
of a new Air Force Base command to take
charge of all military space activity
including any new anti-missile defense
pay careful attention to protecting
promoting our interest in space Pentagon
officials say it's the first step toward
eventually putting weapons into space
Mr secretary the budget proposes
spending 8.3 billion dollars on the full
range of ballistic missile defense
programs
this is an increase over last year of
nearly 60 percent or three billion
dollars it is a lot of the taxpayers
money on the other hand the president
intends to have ballistic missile
defense to protect the population
centers of the United States as well as
of our friends and allies and deployed
forces
foreign
[Music]
foreign
missile event I agree that's a valid
event you have two for track zero zero
zero one today's Air Force fights
missile defense war games in which
so-called Rogue Nations attack American
cities possible impact in San Francisco
sir in reality who would launch such
attacks against the USA
the interesting thing is that the threat
is actually shrinking not increasing
the ballistic missile threat is
declining there are far fewer ballistic
missiles in the world now than there
were 15 years ago there are fewer
countries with ballistic missile
programs there are fewer hostile
countries to the United States with
ballistic missile programs
when you start when you look at it it
really comes down to a to a handful of
States whose programs we worry about
North Korea and Iran basically and they
only have medium-range missiles that is
they can't reach the United States
Reagan onwards
every president has secured funding for
missile defense
under various guises
using various funds for a total of at
least 200 billion dollars
our U.S taxpayers getting what they pay
for
it's a con it's a con missile defense is
the greatest fraud in the Department of
Defense and believe me it's had a lot of
competitors
I I will I I really believe this I
missile defense is the longest running
fraud in the in the history of the U.S
Department of Defense
[Music]
a ballistic strike is implausible why
repel it at such cost
from space
what if missile defense disguised
Ambitions broader than destroying only
missiles
there's going to be an inherent
anti-satellite capability with any
ballistic missile defense system
regardless of whether it's located in
space or elsewhere and I think that
that's effectively unavoidable targeting
a ballistic missile in some senses is
more difficult than targeting a
satellite and therefore targeting a
satellite is almost always a capability
that's associated with missile defense
system
in February 2008 the United States
destroyed a disabled satellite of its
own with missile defense interceptors
the U.S demonstrated that these
interceptors also called kill Vehicles
can obliterate any satellite and low
earth orbit missile defense is the
Trojan Horse
that has nothing to do with defense
whatsoever it's all about projecting
power it's about offense
I've been to the bases in Colorado
Springs and I've personally seen over
the door where it says master of space
and I've read the document's vision for
2020 and a whole array of other military
space command documents that have said
for years that the U.S will control
space that we will dominate space that
we will deny other countries access the
space we five percent of the world's
population in the United States
are going to deny other countries access
to space I mean absolutely provocative I
would tell you that we are so dominant
in space that I pity a country that
would come up against us
um the Synergy with their land and sea
forces and and our ability to control
the battle space and Seize The High
Ground is devastating
jobs is until 1727. America now has the
chance to establish an American Empire
of pax Americana that will last for many
many decades
and one of the ways to do this is to
establish
strong American control of space
[Music]
by advancing space Weaponry the United
States nurtures its economy and its fear
of control
it guards interests at home and to the
outermost Frontiers
and the tradition of Empires
if you look at history
countries including the United States
had this at first develop armies that
defend themselves
so the United States needed an army to
defend itself against the indigenous
population who we were Exterminating as
we expanded across the national
territory and to defend ourselves
against
Mexico and we stole half of Mexico and
so on and so forth for that he needed
armies and also intervention and so on
and then countries also developed navies
like you know the British had to
developed a Navy to defend themselves
against people in India
yeah everything and so on uh and as they
describe it they they're pretty Frank
about it they say they had to develop
navies to protect uh commercial
interests and investment uh and same
with that and now there's a new frontier
space and we have to
move on to control space in order to
protect commercial interests and
investment
Welcome To The Future
the place you go when you say Here's to
bigger profits Better Business brighter
prospects and a bottom line that just
won't quit think big big tax advantages
big business opportunities big profits
and the hottest Fortune 500 Industries
in the world are taking advantage of
them
which means whether you're looking to
relocate expand or conquer the known
universe with your own special vision of
a capitalist's dream they can help make
it happen please
[Applause]
it's nice to be here in Colorado Springs
for this this great Gathering and I
think it's fitting that we're here in
Colorado because I think it was yeah I
know it was 25 years ago when the first
commander of Air Force Base command
stood up the flag here General James
hardinger he said that Colorado Springs
would become the nation's military space
capital and indeed it has
in Colorado Springs you will find a
different kind of base of both direct
military and Military contractors
approaching one-third of the entire
population and when you think about it
that is a big number
[Music]
the industrialists are now saying we're
not going to make cars anymore we're not
going to make
clothes in America anymore we're not
going to make this and that in America
anymore
we're going to make weapons
this is our space tracking surveillance
system
and this is a more advanced version of a
missile detection satellite to to detect
track and discriminate missiles in
flight so this finds them somebody else
shoots them down
all kinds of cool stuff we're working on
some of the world's most important and
spectacular Technologies and we're the
best in the world at what we do
[Music]
most U.S Industries struggle to endure a
recession the weaponization of space
still feeds thriving corporations with
contracts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here on our right we see one of the new
guys in town s-i International
companies that are growing very quickly
that no one has heard of before such as
L3 Communications
Sparta these are names that are not
familiar names to people and yet they
are the new strong players in military
contractors
here we have the Aerospace corporation
on your right
you have miter corporation on your left
[Applause]
[Music]
as we cross over here you will see a
Lockheed Martin plant
now here to our right is Northrop
Grumman Northrop Grumman has always been
a big contractor but a couple of years
ago it bought out TRW Corporation and so
now it is one of the biggest military
contractors in the world this is the
kind of New Growth we are seeing in
Colorado Springs
[Applause]
[Music]
out of every tax Dollar in the United
States today 50 cents out of every
single tax dollar goes to the Pentagon
the past Wars for current Wars for
future Wars
[Music]
[Applause]
we are being made into a warrior culture
if you will
[Music]
nearly three quarters of a million
remarkable individuals
serving their country and they all
believe they have the best job in the
world
[Music]
how cool is it to be able to go home at
night and tell your kids that you fly
satellites at geosynchronous orbit that
is great stuff
how cool is it to know that you operate
the most powerful Radars in the planet
and surveil the heavens that you operate
telescopes that are critical to National
Defense
[Music]
how cool is it to tell people that you
are responsible for maintaining nuclear
missiles on alert for the defense of
this country
[Music]
this is a cool business that we are in
join us
America's Air Force
no one comes close
[Music]
this is our larger laboratory in the off
to this side we have freshman or first
year Cadets working on components of our
Falcon sat 5 satellite that we're in the
process of Designing and we'll be
testing those at Kirtland Air Force Base
in New Mexico
since I was a kid I've been fascinated
with Aviation and space exploration so
after high school I started looking at
colleges and the Air Force looked really
cool because I could learn about space
technology and satellite design so the
Air Force Academy was just the Natural
Choice
ah crazy
[Music]
face look number four right there Earth
four okay awesome we're at the Air Force
strawberry slalus Academy at Kirtland
Air Force Base and we've got students
working on a engineering piece of
software to design a space station so if
they were trying to present their model
to somebody to buy or to be excited
about that's cool
there are all kinds of stories across
the country now where young people in
their schools are being indoctrinated at
very young ages in this Warrior culture
and in new space technology
each year over 50 000 children are
educated in space technology at military
bases in Most states across the U.S
[Music]
it's a long-term view seeking to enlist
generations of Youth in richly
subsidized Aerospace careers
extremely important for us to have
students learning about science
technology engineering and Mathematics
as our Workforce continues to age we
need to make sure that we have young
people in the pipeline that are
interested in filling those career slots
that our future our current scientists
and Engineers are in
[Music]
I would argue there is no better time
than today for us all to commit
to a future of excellence and Leadership
fueled by the next generation of our
Airmen ladies and gentlemen we're ready
today with our great industry partners
with you at our side we'll be ready for
tomorrow God bless you and thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the Pentagon has said that moving the
arms race into space will be the largest
industrial project in the history of the
planet Earth
they can't take any chances they have to
have an enemy they have to make the
people afraid someone's going to attack
us with nuclear weapons we've got to
have missile defense in order to protect
us from Attack Iraq
one of the Rogue States Iran
North Korea and now they throw China
into that equation
wait a minute
what about the Chinese threat
didn't China like the U.S show that it
can destroy orbiting satellites
isn't China trying to gain military
superiority in space
for our space security is real kind of
an electronic Pearl Harbor that could
only be aimed at the United States there
are individuals who are hyping the
Chinese threat saying that it's imminent
that it's aggressive that they plan to
launch a preemptive massive attack on
U.S Space Systems in the Pacific uh
which they call a space Pearl Harbor and
they often look for these stories these
Sensational stories in newspapers or
tabloids and these Publications tend not
to be very reliable
for example this parasite satellite
story
where a Hong Kong tabloid published a
bit of information it got off of a
Chinese website and then this made it
into U.S pentagon reports to Congress
and nobody ever bothered to figure out
if this original Chinese website Source
was credible or not and as it turns out
uh the the person who was posting this
it was on his personal web page his sort
of own personal blog and he was really
just sort of making it up and if you
look at all of the other things on his
site which include things like pictures
of you know Stanley clad women and
Sensational photographs of secret weapon
systems he's clearly not a credible
source of information
foreign
they didn't bother to trace the
information to its source which took us
about six hours to do
for the last three years the Pentagon
has been trying to make China the new
Boogeyman and China unwittingly played
into the United States hands with its
anti-satellite test
[Music]
at the time I was at a conference in
Colorado Springs and the military
officers in the room actually left to
watch the test in real time
so they were observing the actual
Chinese anti-satellite test
we know about every space launch we know
about every rocket launch we have
reconnaissance and surveillance
satellites that can detect all these
we detected the Chinese test for example
and in fact we detected the two previous
Chinese tests that failed
so we know about this it's extremely
difficult to hide
space tests they're one of the most
observable weapons tests you can
possibly imagine
foreign
of China's display of Destruction
the reason is simple they want to give
you a signal a warning so the warning
must be known by the other side in a
fact the Chinese were saying
okay you want to be dominant in space
you deal with us
China intended to alert the world to U.S
plans for military dominance of space
[Music]
and China warned it will confront that
ambition
it is able and willing to destroy U.S
weapons in space
we wouldn't really want to see
in the future an earth surrounded by an
outer layer of weapons which will make
mankind even more vulnerable than the
situation today
China offered a preview of The Deadly
contest that would start
if the U.S positions weapons in space
how close is that risk
the U.S military is developing what the
Air Force in particular has called
prompt Global strike that is basically
currently we have nuclear missiles that
could strike anywhere on Earth within 30
minutes
what the military is talking about is a
similar conventional capability that
could be used to knock out say a Chinese
anti-satellite weapons launcher in a
matter of minutes
a number of concepts are being studied
with this notion of prompt Global strike
one is a orbiting space plane that would
have the capability to be able to
maneuver and also to fire weapons at a
much faster Pace than is currently the
case
another is a space satellite that would
actually have missiles on it that could
be fired from space and reach a Target
in literally uh five to ten minutes as
opposed to the current 30 minutes
we're talking about a satellite a system
called rods from God which can put heavy
tungsten metal rods from satellites onto
the Earth to penetrate bunkers
all that's being developed we've spent
uh billions of dollars on research on
these on these weapons and a number of
these weapons are getting ready for
testing
were they deployed in orbit Global
strike systems could hit 100 targets on
Earth at once at nearly 7 000 miles an
hour
they wouldn't be weapons of mass
destruction as defined in U.N
resolutions but the destructive impact
of a rod from God would match that of a
nuclear warhead satellites can identify
a Target through overhead imagery
process Communications about the target
between military decision makers and
then guide a bomb precisely enough to
destroy the target with one shot
would it really be that big a step if a
projectile itself were also launched
from space
There's no practical difference and I'd
venture to say that the person on the
receiving end wouldn't see the
distinction either
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the high-tech field there's a notion
called normal accent it means the kind
of accident that is going to take place
unpredictably in any complicated system
like anyone who owns a computer knows
about normal accidents every once in a
while I don't think there's crashes for
some unexplained reason and when you get
to much more complex systems of course
that's going to happen
with all our technology we know bloody
well that we cannot be assured
absolutely 100 percent that our bombs
so-called think bombs smart bombs are
hitting the targets we know from
Afghanistan and Iraq alone in the last
few years that that that's a fallacy you
are hitting civilian people
how much worse would the probability of
hitting the wrong target or hitting
ourselves
from outer space would be we have no way
of calculating that it's not possible
at least one weapon could go awry and
land in Iowa or New York City or God
knows where you know uh that's a reality
and if if we don't accept that well
we're just whistling in the dark and
we're going to be victims of our own
technology
[Music]
uh
foreign
space of course so there have been an
efforts to
renew and extend the outer space treaty
it says weapons of mass destruction
can't be in space it doesn't say other
things and there have been attempts to
renew it just to affirm it and to
strengthen it
now the U.S blocks it every year
[Music]
[Music]
it is
160 to one 170 to 1. the United States
is the only nation actually voting
against this we're isolated on this
issue
[Music]
it would be nice to think that space
weaponization is prevented not because
there's a huge outcry against it
although that would be an interesting
Prospect too but because no one
including our own nation has the money
to spend on this anymore but in an era
when the United States still maintains a
500 billion dollar military budget every
year I don't think we can count on that
happening it's really insane we are
willing to spend hundreds of billions of
dollars over the years to develop
space control means that a treaty would
take care of would make unnecessary if
we had the will to negotiate such a
treaty if we took the lead
we could get one it wouldn't be easy it
would be a very difficult thing to do
but it could be done
[Music]
ground-based laser a conventional
missile and most orbiting systems can be
used to demolish satellites
could a treaty guarantee that kill
Vehicles would only target missiles not
satellites or Earthbound objects
components of a new treaty argue that
such promises are untenable
and too late
[Music]
weaponization of space has happened a
long time ago
this idea that it's a pristine
environment that if only we stop where
we are right now
all will be well is simply nonsense and
it's even more foolish to think that
somehow we can stuff this Genie into a
bottle
we do indeed need a United Nations
treaty this is not enough this is only
step one step two says okay
space has been militarized there are
military networks in space many of them
like GPS are useful but we should work
on International treaties to make those
military space networks used for
multilateral purposes do I think that's
going to happen I'm I'm very doubtful
but I have to keep hoping and believing
that there is a prospect for that
[Applause]
I will cut tens of billions of dollars
in wasteful spending
cut investments in unproven missile
defense systems I will not weaponize
space
those fearing the weaponization of space
could find Hope in Barack Obama's
election
as soon as he took office the White
House announced it would be seeking a
worldwide ban on weapons that interfere
with Military and Commercial satellites
[Music]
but it proved tough to change Decades of
entrenched military policy to weaponize
space
[Music]
Obama's 2010 defense budget requested
close to a billion dollars that was
applicable to Space Warfare systems
it included a new program called
offensive counter space which the
Pentagon defined as offensive measures
to disrupt deny
degrade
or destroy any adversary space
capabilities
[Music]
history suggests that Nations do not
voluntarily disarm
they disarm because they're defeated
or they make small adjustments in the
way they buy and build and deploy their
weapons
but no superpower says you know it would
be better if we were weaker
I don't recall that ever happening
[Music]
it's hard to obtain space superiority
without attacking so I'm afraid that if
we want space superiority we're gonna
have to attack enemies assets which
I don't know if you know much about
orbital mechanics but if you created
debris up in space that would just get
in the way for you as well and it kind
of started chain reaction and pretty
soon you just have a cloud of debris
surrounding Earth
about 600 000 fragments rush through
space
ten times the velocity of a rifle bullet
all of these objects are traveling at 14
000 miles an hour
so even an object the size of a p
traveling at that speed has more Force
than a than a cannonball
right now the problem with space junk is
so high that NASA is worried that if
there is never another launch of
anything into space
because every launch creates a little
bit of debris
in 50 years time certain orbits will be
so polluted that nobody can operate
there
because the stuff that's already up
there will start breaking up and
creating more and more clutter
[Music]
lights destruction
unleashes a storm cloud of debris
bowels the space around our planet
and threatens anything in orbit the
point really is
creation of debris in this manner a good
idea or a bad idea and clearly it is a
very bad idea because there's no way to
go up and clean that up
the more times you go into space and you
begin to practice destroying other
satellites you create so much space junk
that you literally create the very
likely possibility that at some point in
time you will not be able to get a
rocket off the planet Earth because
it'll be like a mine field around the
planet and you won't be able to escape
the Minefield with that rocket because
it would be destroyed by all the space
junk there so we've got to begin to look
at spaces and environment
foreign
we have several hundred billion dollars
of investment in the peaceful uses of
outer space I'm talking about weather
satellites positioning satellites
scientific satellites
the entire world communication network
is all satellite oriented
all this incredible investment
from the United States and from the
European Union in Canada and other
countries like this all this is
completely a Jeopardy if we start
putting weapons in outer space
the world change if we lost the use of
satellites
they won 6 15 a.m communication
satellites hovering over the America's
fall mute over a swath of the globe GPS
coverage collapses
atomic clocks on GPS satellites can't
transmit Universal Standard Time
the synchronization of massive
infrastructures snaps 350 million cell
phones are disabled hundreds of millions
of internet connections vanish
around the world card payments and bank
accounts freeze
billions of dollars are set from
Industries and businesses triggering a
financial crash new services are
crippled
city streets reliant on GPS for traffic
management are in chaos
electrical grids lose synchronization
wide zones of continents are blinded by
blackouts
coast guards are deaf to ship's distress
calls
dozens of aircraft are missing air
traffic controllers are fighting Panic
worldwide flights are grounded or called
back by midnight there's been a Cascade
of traffic train boat and aircraft
accidents
so far
the world has avoided such a catastrophe
but a space War would kill satellites
and blast tons of wreckage into orbit
the system we rely on would shatter
and be impossible to restore
the time 6 25 and this is a special as
part of the conference on world affairs
we're discussing the militarization of
space there is a point in time that may
be rapidly closing where the United
States could dominate space to such a
point where there would be no arms race
frankly I don't think it's doable I I
think the march of Technology will mean
that even if we get a lead on other
nations in attempting to do that that
sooner or later we will again be
challenged
it's kind of like what happened after
World War II and we had the atomic bomb
nobody else had the atomic bomb we
thought we had a big exclusive and
without Atomic weaponry
we would be able to dominate the Earth
it didn't last very long the Soviets had
an atomic bomb the Chinese had an atomic
likewise in space to think that we can
move up there with weaponry and be alone
to be the the King on the uh the Throne
of space is a tragic miscalculation
is special
India has been discussing whether or not
it needs to build its own anti-satellite
weapons you can be sure if India does it
Pakistan will be thinking about it in a
heartbeat as well Israel has also been
discussing this issue so what you see
now is the potential for a domino effect
willingly submit to U.S Supremacy in
space
some will try to topple the U.S others
Scramble for a foothold enemies will buy
leaping ahead stable and unstable
Nations will be dragged into the race
the European Union opposes the
weaponization of space
but for how long
is
the place is
Russia would plunge into the contest
it has committed to destroying any
weapon the U.S positions in orbit
if Americans deploy
space-based anti-ballistic missile
defenses then could you imagine
interceptors based on space stations
military stations would overfly
territory of Russia or territory of
China that would be considered as a
quite unacceptable I think for Russians
the potential victims are not going to
say here's my throat please cut it they
know that they're a potential Target and
if the U.S were to develop space weapons
they'd be
completely defenseless unless they
destroyed it somehow or developed a
deterrent and deterrence are known so
for example nuclear weapons are a
deterrent uh terror is a turn now that's
why aggressive militarism leads to an
extension of proliferation and Terror
[Music]
ism
foreign
[Music]
humankind feared that in a series of
blinding flashes the world would become
an untended graveyard
[Music]
thousands of nuclear weapons are still
maintained around the world on hair
trigger alert
the weaponization of space could
detonate this Arsenal
so any anxiety induced by putting
weapons in space or launching weapons
from space down to earth
could induce by accident by human
fallibility by design by terrorist
takeover the launching of up to 9 000
hydrogen bombs inducing a short Ice Age
in the death of most creatures on the
planet
we're on the edge of the nuclear
precipice about to be annihilated
foreign
if we move to weaponization of space we
can bid farewell to the planet
now the chances of survival are very
slight
[Music]
when you all your life have been told
that America
is a exceptional Nation we are different
from the rest and you're told that all
your life you begin to believe it
[Applause]
or Force I was a young Republican for
Nixon
and I grew up on the military bases
behind the barbed wire fences and so
everything I really was taught and was
trained in was militarism and a
conservative way of being conservative
way of seeing the world
[Applause]
but now I personally have learned
that what America is doing is not about
defense it's about offense
it's about an aggressive military
doctrine that talks about control and
domination
I really went through an entire
transformation everything that I knew
was different but one thing wasn't
different one thing always remained I
realized I had a good heart even as a
conservative as a young follower of the
military I had a good heart I I had a
good intention and I realized that many
people in the military are that way that
they have a good heart they mean well
they're they're doing what they think is
the right thing to do they want to
protect the country
there are moments that will truly test
the leader within you
test whether you will take the hard path
or the easy path
the wrong path or the right path most
people want to have a good heart and
that when you challenge them to think it
doesn't mean that they change overnight
I didn't change overnight it took me
some time behind those Gates on that
military base for me to make my change
but it's all about initiating that
change the willingness always to take
the right
even if it's the hard path
is called Carrick
in every aspect of your life whether
personal or professional you must always
maintain the courage of your convictions
your personal integrity
[Music]
we're living in a very very dangerous
time and there's hardly any alarm in
this area across the board I mean people
are just they're so inundated with so
many things you know just making a
living just getting through the day
just trying to remain sane in all this
Insanity that's going on
that it's hard to get their attention
and saying oh wait a minute I know you
think it's bad I got news for you it's a
lot worse
people people don't want to hear that
you know so we have to find a way to
alert people to the reality of what's
going on
and that's not an easy task
[Music]
let's prevent something terrible from
happening before it does for once
usually we're trying to bring back
weapon systems after they've been
deployed nuclear missiles we're trying
to bring them back here's an opportunity
one of the first times in history
actually that we have a chance to be
proactive we have a chance to stop a new
arms race before it actually happens
that's why this moment is so crucial
foreign
the debate over space weaponization is
the most critical debate for the next
century and we are on the verge
of making decisions
in Many Nations around the world about
which path to choose
[Applause]
congratulations may God watch over all
of you and
the Lord we pray today that you would
allow us to worship you in spirit and in
truth as we go out into the world
can The High Ground that Nation seek be
the moral High Ground
or are we doomed to pursue Only The High
Ground of military advantage
many nations are showing themselves
unwilling to find Global Peace under the
command of one
[Music]
show leadership rather than strive for
Supremacy
rather than insisting on a Pax Americana
can the U.S steer a union of Nations
towards a Pax universalis
a piece for all the world
in Christ's name we pray
amen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not a packed Americana
enforced On The World by American
weapons of war
I am talking about genuine peace
kind of peace that makes life on Earth
worth living
not Millie peace for Americans
peace for all men and women
not merely peace in our time
peace and all time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]